[Applaudissements]
tenir darkmout à tout prix un objectif
crucial pour ses soldats Ukrainiens
déterminés à ne pas lâcher autre Prusse
cette ville de l'est de l'Ukraine malgré
les combats acharnés la situation serait
stable sur le terrain selon certains
officiers Ukrainiens
à 5
nous devons reconnaître les succès de
l'ennemi
il y a les troupes régulières russes et
leur artillerie tire avec précision
le plus chaud du conflit une bataille
violente et meurtrière comparable pour
certains à celle de Verdun lors de la
première guerre mondiale
les Russes encercle la ville et
parviennent à gagner du terrain mais au
prix de pertes humaines extrêmement
lourdes
ils ont beaucoup d'effectifs ils
envoient beaucoup de troupes je ne pense
pas que ce soit durable pour eux de
continuer à attaquer de cette façon il y
a des endroits où leur corps sont
simplement entassés il y a une tranchée
ou une évacue tout simplement pas leur
blessé ou leur tuer
et continue à envoyer encore et encore
des vagues de soldats
malgré les bombardements intensifs au
moins 5000 habitants sont restés sur
place sur un total de 70 000 avant la
guerre des bénévoles tentent de les
aider tant qu'ils le peuvent et surtout
de les convaincre d'évacuer
vous occupez de beaucoup de choses oui
j'ai des vaches des veaux j'ai pitié de
nous comprenons mais qu'en est-il de
votre vie
j'ai pitié de tout
pour Moscou prendre bac mood permettrait
d'engranger un premier succès militaire
après de nombreux revers ces derniers
mois une victoire qui ouvrirait à
l'armée russe la route vers sloviance
qui est cramator les deux dernières
grandes villes du don-basse région que
le Kremlin souhaite conquérir dans sa
totalité